you il ya quelques jours je mate est une
compilation de fail et s'est passé ça et
je me suis demandé mais pourquoi ça me
fait rire de mater quelqu'un qui fait
une chute comme ça eh ben pour y
répondre
aujourd'hui on va parler du rire du pacs
le pour vous noterez que je suis revenu
au basin chez moi tranquille vous a
voulu youtube dès 2013 me manque un
petit peu
henri bergson saint flour français
d'origine polonaise de la fin du 19ème
début 20e il a eu un prix nobel de
littérature il a beaucoup travaillé sur
l'intuition l'intelligence et la
conscience bref plein de trucs hyper
important et si là vous le voyez avec
une veste en cuir c'est parce que pour
que cette vidéo soit bien elle n'a
besoin de berck ce nom en harley david
pearson il a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle le rire est dans ce livre il
se pose les mêmes questions que moi en
début de vidéo
on a exactement les mêmes parce qu'à
l'époque ait pas de population de ce
pays etc
vous avez compris l'idée et ces exemples
sont assez explicites et sa structure
est assez clair donc cette offre déjà il
va nous donner trois observations
fondamentale d'abord ce qui est risible
et proprement humain ok genre un paysage
il peut être magnifique moche touchant
sans intérêt ne peut pas être drôle
façades d'immeubles alors là il ya des
gens qui ont peut-être me dire non mais
moi je regarde des vidéos d'animaux sur
instagram je suis désolé ça me fait trop
rire
alors oui c'est drôle mais ce qui fait
rire c'est pas l'animal c'est l'humanité
qu'on lui prête sur le moment par
exemple cette vidéo d'un chien qui
réagit un pet me fait vachement rire à
la par exemple ce qui est drôle c'est
pas le chien en lui-même c'est plutôt le
fait qu'on lui prête une personnalité à
cause de son élégance et son regard un
petit peu snob georges pareil avec les
objets par exemple s'il ya un chapeau
chelou qui te fait rire genre celui là
et bien c'est pas le chapon lui-même
parce que là c'est un chapeau en forme
de dinde intellectuellement parlant
c'est pas hyper marrant en revanche ce
qui est drôle c'est que tu dis [ __ ] ya
des humains qui sont allés assez loin
pour faire un chapeau en forme de dinde
et d'autres qui sont assez cons pour
l'acheter seconde observation bergson va
nous parler d' insensibilité
en gros pour lui le rire s'accompagne
d'une insensibilité et son pire ennemi
c'est l'émotion alors évidemment vous
pouvez rire de quelqu'un qui vous fait
pitié mais dans ce cas-là bergson nous
dit seulement alors il faudra oublier
cette affection faire taire cette pitié
pour lui le rire s'intéresse à
l'intelligence pure et d'un exemple par
exemple pour lui si demain on est dans
une société d'intelligence pur ou
d'imagination et bien on ne pleurerait
sûrement plus mais on rirait encore est
l inverse si on était dans une société
hyper sensible où chaque événement avait
de grosses conséquences sentimentale et
bien on ne verrait plus du tout petit
est ce que tu te rends compte
ouais ah bon elle a quand même bouffer
la lessive quoi excuse moi me faut être
sacrément con de la lessive quoi et vous
l'espérez à laval l'estomac ou quoi que
ce soit on peut plus rigoler ras la
casquette de tout ça on dire internet
c'est troisième et dernière observation
le rire a une dimension collective
sociale et se propage
il est contagieux et vous l'avez
sûrement vécu en plus il ya de gens dans
une salle de théâtre qui rigole et puis
il y a de chances que vous vous y
mettiez aussi voilà tout ça c'est pour
les caractéristiques du rire et ensuite
il va expliquer ce qu'est pour lui le
comique
qu'est ce qui est comique et pour ça il
va partir de deux exemples d'abord il va
prendre l'exemple de quelqu'un qui
trébuche et qui tombe dans la rue et
ouais on boucle sur l'exemple dans
l'introduction
et ouais bah oui quand même c'est comme
ça tu crois qu'on est là pour trier des
lentilles oui je veux bien mon taf ou
pas mais bien sûr je sais te faire
quelque chose de bien bien sûr il prend
c'est un autre exemple
c'est une personne qui va vouloir
utiliser son encrier mais en fait c'est
de la boue et qui va vouloir s'asseoir
mais la chaise se casse du coup la
personne s'étale par terre donc il ya
cet exemple une personne qui chute dans
la rue pourquoi c'est drôle peut-être
parce que la personne souffre
donc ça marrant alors pas tout à fait en
fait pour berck sonne on va avoir d'un
côté la vie qui est un mouvement fluide
souple avec une flexibilité et de
l'autre une raideur mécanique qui
s'opposent à ça si je reprends les deux
exemples on va voir la personne qui
marche comme ça paf fluidité de la vie
flexibilité et puis d'un coup elle
trébuche elle tombe pas raider mécanique
comme si la personne continuer son
mouvement comme un automate au lieu de
ralentir et quand on est l'obstacle
et c'est pareil dans notre exemple la
personne elle va continuer à écrire
s'asseoir et c'est sans changer ses
plans et s'adapter à ce qui se passe
eh ben pour bergson ça c'est la clé du
comique et résume ça en une phrase du
mécanique plaqué sur du vivant
d'ailleurs c'est aussi pour ça que
l'imitation ça nous fait rire parce
qu'on extrait de la personne tout ce qui
est mécanique chez elle comme ses tics
ou sa façon de parler
donc on rend la personne comique et là
j'ai imité une grue et il était choqué
j'ai pas compris
bizarre time it et ça comment battus à
gt droit comme ça car la main droite
aussi et j'ai fait comme ça poweo mec au
waou
je suis désolé je suis désolé ma part ya
un truc que je comprends pas je fais si
mal la grue que ça et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant parce que personne
n'a approché ça à autre chose de très
important
la société il explique que la vie la
société elle demande de chacun de nous
d'être attentifs aux changements et s'y
adapter la société veut pas juste
convives
elle veut complique bien c'est à dire
que même si on évite les choses comme
les accidents la maladie la folie
donc les choses graves il reste quelque
chose qui la gêne elle ne veut pas qu'on
se laisse aller à des automatismes
facile à des habitudes
elle ne veut pas qu'on est juste un
accord entre nous elle veut qu'on est
constamment une adaptation réciproque
c'est pour ça que pour elle le moindre
signe de mécanique ou de raideurs c'est
une menace et donc elle va pas réagir à
quelque chose de grave parce que cette à
quelque chose qui est grave pour elle
mais ça la gêne donc elle va réagir
avait quelque chose de très léger le
rire comme un signal un rappel à l'ordre
social
bergson dit il a pour fonction
d'intimider en humiliant 6 encore lui -
masi oui la rigole de moi vas-y rigole
du coup et là je m'éloigne est un petit
peu de bergson et me rapprocher tout le
monde
pour vous dire un petit peu ce que je
pense parce que quand on met ça en
perspective avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui je trouve ça très
intéressant
l'humour change et on rit [ __ ] même chose
par exemple bergson disait on rit d'un
chien à moitié tondu un parterre aux
fleurs artificiellement coloré d'un bois
dans les arbres sont tapissés d'affichés
électorales etc
bah c'est faux alors personne ne lit pas
n'importe quoi donc savez sûrement et
devrait effectivement c'est du mécanique
plaqué sur du vivant
ça me paraît totalement logique sauf que
notre relation à la nature
elle a changé notamment à cause des
questions environnementales n'a pas la
même conscience environnementale qu'à
l'époque de bergson
du coup un truc que la société trouvait
juste un petit peu embêtant est devenu
un truc grave
aujourd'hui on rêverait pas de sens
ainsi on tombait sur un bois tapissés
d'affichés électorales
on dirait c'est moche ça gâche le
paysage j'espère que ces feuilles de
papier recyclé et c'est un peu ce qui se
passe avec les vannes sexistes et
racistes comme on disait au début de la
vidéo
rires seulement une insensibilité or la
société est elle en train de prendre
conscience de certaines choses dont elle
n'avait pas conscience avant donc
parfois on n'a plus envie de se montrer
publiquement avec cette insensibilité là
donc on répond j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu ça m'a fait plaisir de faire
un coup de fil
j'espère que ça vous a plu d'un regard
des 1 et si vous voulez m'encourager en
faire plus
n'hésite pas à le partager ou à m'offrir
un café sur tipi ainsi les meilleurs
signaux vous puissiez m'envoyer j'ai pas
parlé des différents types d'humour
qu'il y avait selon lui on serait rentré
dans un truc un petit peu descriptif
mais je vous ai mis des liens se voulait
aller plus loin dans la description et
je voulais aussi un lien affilié si vous
voulez choper le livre je sais pas non
plus parler de la conception de l'humour
selon sigmund freud très rapidement pour
lui le rire c'est une manière d'évacuer
des sujets qui sont prisonniers parce
que nous impose la vie sociale
c'est un peu le mois qui libère ses
pulsions du ca faso sûrement
je pourrais peut-être une vidéo sur
l'humour selon freud faut savoir que
bergson et freud ont travaillé ces
questions en même temps et d'ailleurs
les deux se font des références dans
leur oeuvre sur le sujet voilà je crois
que c'est tout on soit évidemment jeudi
à la même heure d'ici là portez vous
bien
n'hésitez pas à faire tout ce qui peut
m'aider au niveau de la lgo parce que ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas fait vidéo
donc là je reviens
voilà je sais pas comment la halle
gauvin accueillir mais voilà n'hésitez
pas à tous les commentaires là avec
machin je vous laisse vous laisse gérer
cette partie là love peace
[Musique]
que faire